today marks the national day of prayer
it's a day that encourages americans to
pray for our country
its people and its leaders the tradition
of a national day of prayer dates to
1775 when the second continental
congress set aside a day for americans
to pray
to be ever under the care and protection
of a kind providence
as they began the struggle for
independence in 1952 congress and
president truman
established a national day of prayer as
a yearly event
and president reagan designated the
first thursday in may
forevermore but our devout catholic
commander-in-chief raised some eyebrows
today by
not mentioning the word god during his
national day
of prayer proclamation the first
president ever to do so
we have the perfect guest to discuss the
issue joining me now reverend franklin
graham before we get to the significance
of the day
i saw you put out a facebook post just
moments ago reacting to the reality that
joe biden
didn't even mention god how can you do
that on the national day of prayer
you know i don't know and i'm not sure
that yeah he even knows
it's probably a staff person that wrote
it and maybe not even ranted by him i
don't
know because i don't think joe biden
would have approved that one uh
this is the national day of prayer of
course we we need to call on god
not just some generic gods or some
power in the air but on god himself the
creator
who made and created this earth and who
sent his son jesus christ from heaven to
this earth
to save mankind from sin by dying on a
cross and
god raised him to life and we there's no
one else to pray to except to god
and for joe biden to miss that i just
think
maybe it was a staffer that did that and
he wasn't even aware
so i would like to give the benefit of
the doubt to
president biden very graceful from you
to do so let's hope indeed that is
correct
i'm on the wrong camera now i'm in the
right one uh reverend real quick
uh the the idea of prayer the power of
prayer
uh you know some people dismiss it
church attendance is down
what what would you say to people who
doubt the power of prayer
well first of all church attendance is
down because churches have been closed
by the president by different government
governors across this country so yes
church attends
down when your church is closed but we
found the churches that are closed
uh the ones that were online actually
had more people watching online
and giving went up so i think uh
we just need to look at uh maybe this
next year and see where we are
but the power of prayer no question god
answers prayer
he hears prayer he listens to prayer but
we got to approach god in the right way
we have to confess our sins and ask for
his forgiveness
and not not go to him with with dirty
hands
so to speak but with a clean heart and
uh
and then ask him then always to ask that
your will be done
because god god wants the best for us he
doesn't want the worst he wants the best
absolutely and so we have to always ask
that god god's will to be done
reverend we are a flawed nation like
every we are all
sinful human beings in need of god's
redemption
would you be willing to offer up a brief
word of prayer for us tonight on the
program
absolutely father we pray for our
country
pray for the president and father we
pray for all the folks there at fox news
our father we thank you for them and we
just pray for pete and his family
thank you father that you love us you
care for us and that you sent your son
jesus christ from heaven to this earth
to die for our sins and our place
and father is my prayer that many people
put their faith and trust in him
it's jesus name we pray amen amen
franklin reverend graham reverend
franklin graham thank you so much the
crusades your father did billy graham
i was one in minneapolis and one in new
york city helped change my life and
shaped my life and i'm grateful for the
mission you continue to do today to
spread the gospel
reverend thank you so much well thank
you god bless
god bless hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else